(opera music)
- [Pizza Guy] Hey!
That's my car, you bastard!
- [Driver] Yah!
(laughs)
We got his pizzas!
- [Passenger] The village
will eat for weeks!
(trumpets)
- Shh!
Shh!
- Hey, hey, hey!
Hey, you with the hair!
Would you like-a slice
of the pizza?
- Would you like a slice
- [Driver] Do you want
a nice slice of pizza?
(honking)
- Would you like
a slice of pizza?
(cheer)
- Ah, and the crush-a pepper!
Give her the crush-a pepper!
The crush-a pepper.
(Driver laughs)
(rock music)
(lounge music)
- Oh, god.
- Ha ha!
Check it out!
That's me!
(rock music)
(theater audience laughs)
- [Magician] Sir, would
you like to see some magic?
I'll want you to
pick one mentally.
I'll turn my back.
Someone wanna cut
the deck for me?
- I will.
- You know.
Pick out one of the cards.
You can pick out a couple, but
it'll make the
trick a lot harder.
(jazz music)
(laugh)
(rock music)
(theater audience laughs)
- Who here's taking the bus?
Who's takin' the bus?
Have a great day,
people on the bus!
It's my bus match!
You like that?
'Kay, ready?
Here we go!
(makes driving noises)
Dah!
Okay.
(makes driving noises)
(rock music)
(applause)
(laughter)
- Who else wants
a slice a' pizza?
- [Passenger] You
wanna slice a' pizza?
- [Driver] How about
a slice a' pizza?
Oh! He's got his own pizza pie!
(lounge music)
(speedy orchestral music)
- Click here to subscribe
for more videos,
or these bees are gonna get ya.
(bathtub draining)